so $1,500 for an abortion they are
incentivized to upsell if you're in
there and you're in there and you don't
want to have an abortion they have an
incentive to push you in that direction
and they do that Planned Parenthood is
effectively becoming not becoming
they've always been that they're
salesmen they're nothing more than awful
terrible used-car salesmen but have you
ever considered an abortion but I wanted
to keep my baby daughter keep my baby's
sanctity of life nothing well Julie
right there's an abortion and crazy
breed has got some good news for you
here the greater pitch Planned
Parenthood I'm offering abortions at
prices so low
people say got crazy that's right here
at Planned Parenthood we're offering
abortions on a sliding scale based on
income that means unless you make the
less you baby
here at Planned Parenthood we have a
history of which we are tremendously
proud one where Margaret Sanger wanted
to ensure quality abortions at
affordable prices set up across the
lowest income earners and urban centers
in America I'm so crazy about affordable
abortions that I'm practically giving
them away efforts in the trash that's
how much I care about you even better if
you some admission you have some history
and you will slash your present I'm
talking to you people of color that's
right it's gonna the markets and and
special every Negro let's go thanks to
federal funded in our sliding scale
payment system colored vote practically
brightened up to the Dow
even better if you come on down to crazy
preach Planned Parenthood in the next
fiscal quarter with every abortion not
thrown in a free mammogram but only
refer so what are you waiting for lose
that fight label it crazy beaten Planned
Parenthood do all the heavy lifting
come on in for a limited time only
baby coughing just come on down to
praise a breach plan for an abortion
going to call five five five bad for my
legal dream pray go five five five five
four five five and crazy people turn
that catchphrase into your reality
that's nine four five five for the
sliding scale Negro disco free mammogram
with belly and baby call from enterprise
solo crazy hey if you like this video
subscribe by clicking the button that
says subscribe if you're not aware of it
now there's no way you're learning the
Internet at this point I'm not going to
help you but this was clipped from my
daily show available exclusively to Lata
with credit.com slash mug Club members
of your student military or veteran
entering that promo code it's less than
six dollars a month and you get daily
content no more clips Plus this hand at
smug oh I just when I feel it I got a
chill like on the inside